the word took a lot from this place
we all started from this wellness and it
has to remain on us otherwise we lost
our identity we lost part of us
[Music]
I am part of the next generation of
women that have to make sure that this
place survives
[Music]
[Music]
it's difficult to explain to somebody
who did not know what was he but myself
I knew what was here we are in Gorongosa
National Park in southern Africa very
close to the Indian Ocean
tourists they used to come from all over
the world and animal populations used to
be huge
whoa in Mozambique was very terrible 1
million people died when the country
faces war nasha is first to face
challenge
animals has been poached to buy firearms
and equipment to feed soldiers 90% of
animal population disappeared
our mission of this park is to restore
the Gorongosa ecosystem not only nature
but also to develop human beings as a
women especially in a science field and
the beginning was really bad
I remember the well my first time in the
field and the Rangers would say no I'm
not going with you to the field because
you are women you a girl you won't make
it
I've been tracking this elephants for
two months
[Music]
so this fight racing
I can't see footprints but is very fresh
there's not even time beetles on it yet
they went into the forest
this other women extremely brave that do
patrols every day the ranges
[Music]
with imitation DC DD fish can approve
Akio Korea trample our a prio consider
Avance are eaten by comeon Vida program
Toronto Blue Train amento Davao a very
key otras cosas edifice economy Larry my
non-scary I am prayin - Jane Tom
Giavotella because of Isaiah form the
new stamp a Occidental very poor - boys
a tumble version a year
[Music]
within English temple I'll be doing that
again
in a human before Jeb Bush
[Music]
a wonderful account is an image softly I
want to walk up there in that way
in Indian Court rowdy Kappa TAS wanted
our
somehow proteges towards animals
resolving a bargainable engine
[Music]
[Music]
yatta-pelican WA Nimal into grand
Colleen McGrath the grant of such money
sa a little fun
what will happen to us if kills an
uneducated what would this world be I
mean
kan course area travel upon different
nerve and AMA and abandoned a movie -
preguntas paranoid
[Music]
the girls club there's a platform where
girls can talk and share their ideas
share their challenges I didn't have a
very smooth childhood not because my
parents were not good know when the
country was just me
we were poor and we had many many
difficulties it's just what many other
African girls are also going into
[Music]
a oh and I see Nevada I see crazy lodge
- de la magnesium for fashion no eres
intimate conversation on per government
salad add my name same thing only for me
the same place beside an African name
the moon taco is a mushroom opossum
insert a non-supported tip down on the
cysteine it's important to remind them
that doesn't add the door for them that
they can be something they can break
that circle and they can fly
[Music]
[Music]
it's important to to do something in my
country because otherwise so well
[Music]
[Music]
juicy like it just gonna do the words
we have Elly's don't charge be nice
tonight oh yeah
gonna go to the water look at that one
rusting the trunk and the others on the
younger you see that the biggest inna
connects me with elephants is the
empathy they do anything to protect
their family they're capable to forgive
even when humans has done so many bad
things to them the elephant population
is recovering we see an increase in the
numbers and I am seeing a lot of new
babies being born
[Music]
Google's is growing and is driving the
park as a new vision in the new model
some of our initiatives already been
taken and adapted to other parks a
Mozambique so yes go go second ad has a
role model for other places
people need nature and people must take
care of nature formosa don't cry we are
going to plant what is needed here you
are taking care of you
people are now looking and feeling
connected again with nature because of
girl goes especially for girls
they want to be biologists they want to
be conservationists now we have women
ranges for our communities from the
buffer zone
[Music]
it is a gate you know for all these
women
they're seen discharged when they're
taking it
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]